so now you're here and you're like yo
Tom is I need this logo hatch house it's
gonna be my name I'm like that's a sick
name and then you're like should I put a
house for the a I'm like yeah yeah and
then you're like
I had both like yo
all right we're killing a lot though we
need to get up and do some it's
like I push trees and but it just
got deleted awesome guys don't forget
right Thomas was very established more
than I was so like even though me
hanging out with Thomas and him talking
was helping me out a lot so we were
hanging all the time but I was like
Thomas was like oh hash house and I was
like oh damn this is great so Thomas
really helped bring my comment while we
were chilling we were just chilling yeah
we're just chilling like organic
chilling and just like supported the
brand you know what I'm saying so like
that got me to like a different level
even though we're just hanging out I
wasn't really working much because it
like it made someone that was like
relative it's like oh stuff's good so
then people were like oh what's this and
the first person